LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE.
HAMILTON WILL STAY ON THE ICE.
DO YOU WIN THE DRAW AGAIN?
THE ONE THAT TIED THE GAME WAS
PARTIALLY WON.
McGINN IS AGAIN ON THE ICE.
>> Mike: HAMILTON AND SLAVIN
WHO CONNECTED ON THE GOAL.
SCORE!.
THE SERIES IS OVER.
JACCOB SLAVIN, SENDING THE
HURRICANES INTO THE SECOND
ROUND.
>> Tripp: WHAT A MOMENT.
THE IMPORTANCE OF FACE-OFF,
HOWEVER YOU FEEL ABOUT IT.
NOW THE WINNER.
THE CAROLINA HURRICANES HAVE --
. THEY APPLY BETTINA DID A
TERRIFIC JOB.
WE ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
HURRICANES AND EVENTUALLY THE
CREW WILL GET THE GOAL.
IT WAS A PARTIALLY WON DRAW.
THEM BACK TO THE POINT.
YOU GOT TO THE FRONT.
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF TIPPING
OPTIONS.
WHAT A BATTLE THIS WAS.
I AM LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
REPLAY.
>> Mike: THIS IS THE BEST
MOMENT IN ALL OF PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS
TWO SIDES THAT WENT TOOTH AND
NAIL FOR SIX GAMES.
A HANDSHAKE LINE BETWEEN THE
VICTORS AND VANQUISHED IS
ALWAYS SOMETHING TO WATCH.
>> Tripp: HURRICANES, YOU HAVE
TO LOOK AT THE MOMENT BEAN
NECAS TYING THE GAME IN
REGULATION  WHERE IT LOOKED
LIKE POSSIBLY NASHVILLE HAD A
HOLD OF THE SERIES AND THEN
JORDAN STAAL, ANSWERING AFTER
THE PREVIOUS TWO OVERTIME
WINNERS.
IN THE THIRD PERIOD, CAROLINA
OUTSCORED NASHVILLE 9-2. THEY
BUILT OFF OF THAT TO SCORE AND
OVERTIME.
YOU SEE ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS
IN ALL OF SPORTS, THE
HANDSHAKE.
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN AT WAR FOR
SIX GAMES.
THAT MUTUAL RESPECT,IT WAS A
HECKUVA PERIOD.
>> Mike: GETTING INTO THAT
SECOND ROUND.
THE CANES HAVE A DATE WITH THE
TAMPA BAY LIGHTNING.
>> Tripp: AHO AND -- . THIS
HAS TO BE COOL.
WHAT THE FUTURE HOLDS FOR
RINNE.
ONE OF THE CLASSIEST GUYS IN
THE HISTORY OF THE GAME.
NEDELJKOVIC, SASE MADE AT
DIFFERENT POINTS IN THE  SERIES
WHEN NASHVILLE COULD HAVE RUN
WILD WITH MOMENTUM.
SAROS WITH SENSATIONAL.
ALSO THAT HUG BUT WE LOVE
BETWEEN SLAVIN AND  TROCHECK.
WHAT YOU MISS AND WHAT YOU GET
BACK.
DOES AHO GET A PIECE?
I STILL DON'T KNOW AND I STILL
DON'T CARE.
>> Mike: AND WAS ABOUT TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, I DON'T
KNOW, I DON'T CARE, I JUST KNOW
THAT THE CANES --
>> Tripp: HE DID. EVEN THOUGH I
KNOW, I STILL DON'T CARE.
>> Mike: THE EXPRESSION SAID IT
ALL.